- So the big news over the weekend,
and it's crazy that the news
cycle has basically moved on,
is that President Trump
tried to work with insiders
in the DOJ to basically launch a coup
inside the Department of Justice.
President Trump worked
with the acting head
of the Civil Division, Jeffrey Clark,
to oust the acting attorney
general, Jeffrey Rosen,
and basically try and shoehorn
all of his crazy conspiracy
theories through the DOJ.
On top of that, it appears
that Trump was trying
to strong arm the DOJ into filing suits
with the Supreme Court to try
and overturn the election.
And the only reason it
appears it didn't work
is that members of the DOJ
threatened to resign en masse
to prevent this from happening.
And they thought that the fallout
from the mass resignations would be worse
than the actual actions itself.
Just when you thought it
couldn't get any worse,
it gets worse, but stay tuned.
And as always, I will see you in court.